(whoosh and beeping)
(electronic music)
- I tend to get unsolicited feedback,
such that should be a very short talk.
(audience laughing)
Isn't that a contradiction of terms.
You mean they found one.
(audience laughing)
And there's like a book a
month that sort of piles on
these unflattering
portrayals, The Primal Teen,
that's actually not too
bad, but Mom, I Hate You,
Get Out of My Life, But First
Drop Cheryl and I at the Mall.
Now I Know Why Tigers Eat Their
Young is right to the point,
Yes, Your Teen Is Crazy.
But with the technology such
as magnetic resonance imaging,
we can for the first
time look under the hood
of the living, growing brain.
And what we've found is that
not only do teens have brains,
(audience laughs)
but they're good brains,
they're as they should
be, they're not broken.
And I'd go so far as to
say if they weren't the way
that they are, we wouldn't even be here.
And evidence from that comes
from kind of unlikely source
I'll get to in a minute.
So the teen brain's different
than the brain of a child,
it's different than the brain of an adult,
it's not just half way between,
it's kind of its own distinct entity,
and it's been exquisitely
forged by evolution
to have certain features.
Behaviorally, the big three
are increased risk taking,
increased sensation seeking,
and a move away from parents to peers.
And I think these are deeply
rooted in our biology,
because it's not just humans,
all social mammals have
these three features.
And so we're probably
fighting Mother Nature
by trying to eliminate these.
And this is always very
speculative to argue these ways,
but one idea is that it
helped us get out of the home,
which is a really irrational
thing to do, okay,
Why, people loved us,
they feed us, protect us,
it's a good gig, right?
But it turns out it works better if we do.
Less inbreeding, it just
sort of, you know, morally,
right around, it just works
better if this happens.
And so these features,
they involved at a time
without firearms, without
high-speed motor vehicles,
without designer drugs and stuff,
so some of these issues are
kind of this stone age brain
in computer age world aspect.
But I think that these
behaviors have virtues as well.
When I was at the NIH,
the Smithsonian Museum,
sort of close, they had this exhibit,
the Hall of Human Origins,
which I really liked,
but kind of not strictly featured
a little placard on the floor,
looked at the relationship
between brain size and climate change.
And the last big increase
in brain size 500, 800,000 years ago.
But what I thought was intriguing was that
what was correlated was
the change in climate,
not the degree.
Before seeing this I thought,
yeah, it got really cold,
you had to be supersmart just
to stay alive long enough
to get food and reproduce.
But this is subtlety different.
Everybody in this room had ancestors
whose brains were good at adaptation.
And we're really good at it in terms of,
even compared to our quite
close, genetically close,
rather in the Neandertrumps,
or Neanderthals,
(audience laughs)
I'll pause, we can edit that later.
(audience applauds)
We can tell enormous amounts from teeth
and fossilized teeth, which
actually we've done it.
Everybody's teeth right now
are fossils, calcified cells.
But they work like trees
so they have rings.
So tree rings, this was a wet
year, a good year of growth,
the rings are wider.
And across many different species,
the rings get closer and
closer as you mature.
The rings stop and you're done growing,
it's done maturing.
And so when you find
these fossilized teeth,
if you find a fossilized
Neanderthal tooth of a 12-year-old,
and then check the rest of the cave,
he's gonna be with his
children, not his parents.
And this is often portrayed
as surprisingly rapid growth
in the Neanderthals.
But I think that's the
wrong way to look at it.
What's surprising is
our protracted growth.
We're the outliers, by far,
it's one of the most
distinctive things about us.
And even across like crows
and many other species,
the longer you're under
protection of your parent,
the more complicated your food gathering,
your communication, problem solving.
Crows are actually really
smart as an example.
But similar crows, in
size and, that don't have
this protected maturation,
don't have those abilities as well.
It doesn't work to just keep your kids
at home until their 40.
I don't think on an individual
basis it doesn't work,
but it's an intriguing trade-off I think
that we keep options open, we
keep our brains changeable,
see what the environment's gonna be like.
We can live on the North Pole,
we can live on the equator,
or everywhere, we can even live
in outer space for a little while
with technologies that
have been developed.
And so this is a good thing, I think,
in terms of this ability
to keep options open
for a long time, but it's
really being put to the test
with the digital revolution.
And this is, just in my
short career is a game changer.
The way that we interact
with like what we're doing
at this moment with ones
and zeroes and the lights,
the projector, it's changed everything,
it's changed the way that we learn,
content that's on internet
and the greatest minds
on the planet are a click
away, you know, for free.
It's just amazing, it's magical.
The way that we play and the way
that we interact with each other.
And so I've been fascinated
by this interaction
in terms of the biology
of this changeability
and the technologies that have
taken over in a sense,
so, of almost 11 hours
a day of screen time,
and 30% of that time more than one device.
And so the usual question
is is it good or bad or
that's the wrong question, right,
almost any interesting
question is it depends
in terms of in what ways
and how it depends and
what it depends upon.
But I think that this is an opportunity
in terms of to influence adolescents.
One of the tragedies of
my profession is that
it's almost a 10-year gap
between onset of illness and treatment.
We need to do better.
And I think perhaps the
technologies can help us get there
in terms of by monitoring things
like social media activity,
maybe even just movement, GPS data,
harnessing these technologies
in an ethically appropriate way
to help us recognize mental illness
so that we can intervene
while the brain is still more changeable.
And so a lot of the debates
around this that there's
it's just not natural, right.
We evolved to talk to each
other, to be with each other,
to share smiles and touches and every,
and now we're looking at screens
for a big part of the day.
But a kind of argument to that
is reading's not natural either.
Reading's only about 5,200 years old.
So most humanity, nobody read.
So I don't think that by
itself is a good argument.
It kind of makes the point
that the whole aspect of this
is the changeability.
10,000 years ago hunting,
gathering berries,
it's the same brain in terms of
that's a blink of an eye
in evolutionary terms.
But our brains are amazing.
We can adapt, you know, a lot
of us spend a lot of our day
with symbols, you know,
words, and that's so different
than you know, what our ancestors did.
And so my career's basically been this
in terms of trying to
understand this plasticity
in terms of how to optimize
the good and minimize the bad.
And this kind of,
how do you help people with mental illness
is the fundamental question.
And so kind of that notion
of like what do we know?
How do we know what we know?
What don't we know?
Why don't we know?
That, but, you know,
my first assumption is
the brain's involved.
I hope so.
It's like a spleen or something,
I'm gonna feel like a
complete fool down the road.
But I think, you know, it's
a reasonable assumption.
And professor Jernigan began this journey,
B.J. and I started together at NH
and following down that path
of looking at the brain,
and how the brain changes
in both typical development
and in illnesses.
It's kind of a noncreative,
started to design, actually,
but scan kids, you
know, when they're young
and follow them as they go through life,
see how they're doing at school, at home,
see what sort of influences
on the brain for good or ill.
And at the NH, we did about 10,000 scans
of half the kids healthy,
half the kids with different illnesses.
And what we found were,
it's nuanced, but like
the brain doesn't mature
by getting bigger and bigger.
By first grade it's
already 93% adult size.
It matures by being more
connected within itself
and more specialized.
And this idea of being more connected,
there's many ways you can approach this,
but white matter is one of them.
So, this insulating material
that you get one to 2% more of
into the fourth or fifth decade,
the brain is able to communicate
amongst itself faster.
It's not very subtle,
it's like 3,000-fold increase in bandwidth
I think underlies a lot of
the remarkable behaviors
that we can do.
But it's not just a matter
of maximizing speed,
it's all about the timing.
And so the fire together
wired together the meaning,
the information's in these patterns.
But more and more we're understanding that
that's the progression.
If we look at different parts of the brain
like letters of the alphabet
as you go from an infant
to child latency, teenagers,
emerging adulthood,
that these letters become words,
the words become sentences,
the sentences, you know,
paragraphs, metaphorically.
And this all goes up in adolescence.
The brain, no matter how you measure it,
whether the molecular, EEG, blood flow,
it becomes more connected.
And this is kind of a fresh look in terms
of this idea of Graph Theory Networks,
it gives us a whole new look.
So, for something like
schizophrenia, before we'd be like,
is this chunk bigger or smaller
or different shape or size?
But looking at the same
MRI scan, the same data,
and looking at how it's interconnected,
then we can discern old from
young, healthy from ill,
'cause their brain,
not perfectly, but it's really
exciting for someone like me
I can't do the math, but
to be a consumer of it
in terms of that,
by looking at this connectivity,
it gives us a whole new
perspective on these illnesses.
The other processes,
the gray matter process
and the one-two punch is
overproduce and then war,
or fight it out.
It's almost all complexity
in nature arises,
engine of evolution,
overproduce something nonrandom selection.
And it has great potential.
So it's constantly on-going,
it's not like you only
overproduce during childhood
and only prune during adolescence,
but that we see this
upside down U-type of curve
where as we specialize, the
brain actually becomes smaller.
So after around 10, 11, 12,
your brain doesn't get bigger,
it gets smaller, but leaner,
meaner, more specialized
based on what you're demanding of it.
But it's not all parts equal.
The prefrontal cortex involved
in controlling impulses,
long-range planning, it's
particular late to settle down.
Some, you know, 25 to 30,
and that combined with
the hormonally-activated,
puberty-activated limbic
system, the passions of words,
this imbalance creates a lot of the
specials of teen behavior aspects.
But again, this is how it should be,
if the prefrontal cortex is already done
like 11 or 12 and stuff, then
we wouldn't be as adaptable.
And so I think this is the
tension or the trade-off.
The other place to start in terms of that
is illnesses happen at different times.
Not perfectly, there's always variation,
but Alzheimer's doesn't
happen when you're three,
and autism doesn't start when you're 60,
that characteristically certain illnesses
tend to emerge at certain ages.
And that's puzzling,
you know, why is that?
In terms of.
And when you start looking at this,
so much happens in
adolescence, not a lot, most.
It's up to 75%,
and I still don't know the answer,
that's been for 25 years,
and we're like why?
Because the early answer is
oh, teenagers are stressful,
it's a stressful time of life.
You know, kids have their
parents killed in front of them,
or they're starving to death
or there's war in 20 countries,
enormous stresses, but they
don't get schizophrenia.
And so that never rang true.
And I still don't know the answer to this,
why do things happen when they do?
And so just one example
is for schizophrenia,
all of the findings you
see in adult schizophrenia,
you can predict what if typical
teen changes went too far?
It's not causal, they
already had schizophrenia,
but so far without
exception, in terms of both
the MRI changes, but also
the molecular changes,
and so it's just this
point, it's intriguing.
It doesn't help me help
families with schizophrenia,
but I think these are the kind of clues
that we're starting to understand.
So, in this specialization process,
in typical development, it's
about 7% from ages 12 to 17,
in schizophrenia, 28%.
So it's not subtle.
You know, four-fold difference.
And so, understanding
the typical development,
I think, is key, but about
half of what I deal with
as an analyst isn't illness.
All right, pregnancy is not an
illness, but it's a big deal.
Relationships, car
accidents, incarcerations,
you know, life decisions, this
happens during adolescence.
And it's frustrating as a physician,
it's like there's no
insurance forms to check
in terms of for these very real issues
that aren't an illness.
And this kind of notion
is the glass half empty or half full?
Because this changeability
could be a great opportunity,
making it even more tragic
that we aren't recognizing
the illnesses when they occur.
And my final sort of analogy
is to use Michelangelo
in terms of this is a very
famous painting of his
that by design should look like a brain,
a cross-section of the brain, he, no,
he wrote about it himself and stuff,
and it's sometimes called
the original synapse,
you know, the.
(audience laughs)
But it's not like that,
it's much more like his other
expression of art, sculpting.
We start with this block of marble,
and life experiences and so,
then we eliminate part.
So we might be born with
different chunks of marble,
sizes from genetics, you know,
but within each, if we
knew what we were doing,
if we could guide this process,
you know, there's masterpieces.
And you know, I think almost everybody.
We don't know very,
we don't know what we're
doing yet very well.
And it's like most of
the illnesses emerging
less than 1-1/2 % of the
funding has been adolescence,
until now finally, now,
we have this project,
that for the first time is
going to really do this right.
11, 12,000 kids, 19
sites across the country
to understand what matters.
How does the brain grow
in health and illness,
looking at, you know, everything
we can think of, frankly,
in terms of influences on this.
I'm gonna brag for San
Diego a bit in terms of
there's these 19 sites across the country,
but the coordinating center
for the quantitative core
and the neuropsyche core
coordinating all the centers
are both here in San Diego as well.
What a good deal for us,
you know, in terms of
the opportunities to try to understand
what matters in teens' lives.
And so the technologies
is a big part of it,
how can we get a better sense
of internal and external environments
with the sensors, with devices
they're already using, already wearing.
'Cause this is the crossroads in life.
This is where people make big decisions
about their direction in life.
And there's this kind of notion
that teens are messed up and
they're misguided and stuff,
and it's dangerous.
And I feel bad, 'cause I've,
(audience laughs)
Oh, I see.
I don't know, people
will be honest with me.
But this is in the crossroads.
And what happens is even teens themselves
buy into this, right?
And like stereotype, thread and stuff,
if you think that you're,
you know, not capable and
stuff like that, it matters.
Most teens do well, you know,
they'll get through this,
they'll do well.
But I think we do a disservice
by selling them short
and I think that we
really need to recognize
the huge upsides of this,
much more than the downsides
that if we can figure out what
we're doing, what matters,
we can really make a big difference.
Thanks.
(audience applauds)
(electronic music)